[Musique]
et stéphanie lorca bonjour bonjour vous
êtes candidate pour les élections
municipales à rivière salée
exact vous êtes membre du mouvement
indépendantiste martiniquais
vous êtes déjà conseillère municipale
d'opposition et vous êtes par ailleurs
conseillère territoriale aussi alors bon
on l'indiqué puisque vous avez déjà une
expérience de campagne électorale en
2014 ou n'être plus tout jeune en
politique mais néanmoins vous restait
tout de même une jeune élue fait oui oui
tout à fait pourquoi avoir choisi d'être
candidate donc à rivière salée pour les
municipales rivière-salée une ville où
le maire est en place depuis 30 ans
maintenant entre les joueurs
tout à fait alors permettez moi de
saluer dans un premier temps les
auditeurs de martinique 1ère et bien sûr
les salines et laissa lien qui nous
écoutent
donc en effet je suis conseillère
municipale depuis plus de dix ans parce
que l'élu depuis 2008
je suis aussi en effet à côté de cela un
conseiller territorial à la collectivité
de martinique
je suis présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales des personnes âgées et
des personnes en situation de handicap
est par ailleurs dans mon activité un
peu plus civil je suis conseillère en
économie sociale et familiale
donc mon job au quotidien c'est
d'accompagner des familles les plus
modestes dont qui appartient à la
famille des travailleurs sociaux et à
côté de cela je suis mon secteur
d'intervention sylla syma qu'une société
de logement social donc c'est vrai que
je suis élu depuis en tous les cas
depuis 2018 je suis à mon nom candidate
de la liste émergences aliens pas de
2018 vous avez dit non en 2014 mais plus
2014 tout à fait depuis 2014
je suis je conduit la liste émergences
aliens avec laquelle je travaille et
c'est vrai que nous avons fait le choix
depuis 2014 dans une dent dans une
opposition constructive parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce que la population
attend de nous c'est que nous soyons
travail que nous soyons dans une
majorité ou dans une opposition et
à côté de ça ça va me permettre d'être
en tous les cas proche de mes valeurs
proches de mes engagements et dans
l'objectif de gagner les élections en
2020 donc aujourd'hui la plus grande
satisfaction dans ce mandat qui se
termine si quelques le maire en place et
président depuis 1989 et qu'aujourd'hui
il s'agit de faire avec les salles et ce
contexte là ses 30 ans de mandature vous
estimez que c'est une chance
supplémentaire pour vous et les autres
candidats alors pas systématiquement
parce que la question de l'âge n'est pas
n'est pas un facteur parce que vous vous
dit
il ya une majorité qui a été choisi à la
gelée ya la durée aussi deux ya là aussi
la question de la durée s'allonge éviter
aux affaires alors exactement décideront
exactement c'est ce que je sais c'est le
principe aujourd'hui les uns et les
autres vont élections pour pour faire
des choix pour faire des propositions
pour être à côté c'est la raison pour
laquelle je considère que en tant qu'élu
même d'opposition qu'on se doit d'être
dans une majorité constructif et je
répète une fois de plus nous avons ce
devoir de travailler pour nous pour nos
administrés il ya un choix qui a été
fait en 2014 on ne sait pas ce qui va
sortir des urnes en 2020 donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes là nous
travaillons avec ma liste émergences
aliens et aujourd'hui ma plus grande
satisfaction c'est que c'est un bon
nombre de nos propositions de 2014 ont
été retenues en tous les cas par la
majorité
on a enfin un site internet pour la
ville de vias ali depuis janvier 2019
il ya de la signalétique en tous les cas
qui a été rénové en fait il y a vous
n'aurez plus rien à proposer
vous savez conclave et là sur les idées
comme ça et là sur les idées ça répond à
un besoin à un instant t nous étions
2014 il y avait des besoins
on les a évoquées on les a proposés à
côté de ça stéphanie les rhodiens
stéphanie lorca parce que le temps passe
très vite est d'accord on est quasiment
arrivé aux cinq minutes tout à fait que
stéphanie norka rapidement justement
quelle école serait là votre urgence si
vous êtes élu en mars 2020 maire de
rivière-salée alors dans un premier
temps il faut savoir que tous et toutes
celles qui vont élections la peau mars
2020 le challenge c'est de faire
beaucoup plus avec beaucoup moins c'est
ça il faut savoir aussi que nous nous
inscrivons dans une élection qui aussi
communautaire
donc l'objectif pour nous c'est de
porter un vrai projet de ville mais qui
s'inscrit aussi dans un projet de
valorisation territoire aujourd'hui
notre objectif simple vous viviez à salé
c'est de faire que je vous dis que nous
ne soyons pas et que rivière salée ne
soit pas la ville ont fait le choix de
venir construire et d'y habiter
mais là où ils sont là où il se passe
des choses là auront fait le choix de
venir là où fait le choix de rester donc
noué vers ça l'est devenu par certains
aspects une sorte de cité dortoir un
petit peu c'est ce que vous dites oui
c'est un peu ça c'est un peu ça depuis
depuis quelques temps il ya quand même
quelques points d'activités faut pas
faux pas des plans de travaux un tableau
qui soit entièrement sombre
aujourd'hui il y a dix améliorations
apportées et pour moi trois grands
chantiers on va pas développer le tout
il s'agit dans un premier temps de la
question l'aménagement du territoire
avec la résorption et de la
problématique de l'indivision qui est
pour moi très important qui me tient à
coeur
sur la question de la lutte contre
l'habitat indigne l'assainissement
l'action économique de proximité je
crois qui est très importante en
direction des acteurs économiques de la
jeunesse mais aussi des seniors et aussi
par rapport à mon métier
fondamentalement l'action sociale de
proximité concertée l'accès au doigt
mais aussi la lutte contre la précarité
je crois que ça c'est important dans
notre société aujourd'hui
merci stéphanie norka une émission
réalisée par édiles aux curieux
clerville bonne journée
je vous remercie